Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
says in a verse of the Quran that the
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam would
recite amongst his nightly recitations
every single night
mentions that the prophet sallall.aii
Wasam would not go to sleep before
reciting
and
also other narrations mentioned that he
would recite
every night and
in
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala reminds the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
reminds us in turn
of the hasty
nature that we have been created upon.
The human being naturally is very hasty
and impulsive
and the human being cannot even be
trusted with his own well-being.
What does that mean? The human being is
so hasty and so impulsive
that he cannot be trusted with his own
well-being.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says in this
verse
he says subhanahu wa ta'ala in one of
its three meanings this verse he says
and the human being prays
for that which is harmful for him with
the same fervor
and energy
that he prays for that which is
beneficial to him. And indeed the human
being is extremely hasty.
He didn't say he said
extremely hasty.
In another verse, Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says,
"The human being is so hasty. He has
been created from haste."
We were created from dust, right? We
were created from mud. We were created
from clay. This is a a form of speaking
meaning that the human being is so hasty
and it is so intrinsic in his nature, he
might as well physically be created from
haste itself.
The human being is haste personified.
In other words,
so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us
here in this verse something very
interesting. He says the human being
prays
for that which is harmful and
destructive to him with the same fervor
and energy
that he prays for that which is of
consequence for him and beneficial and
indeed the human being is extremely
hasty. For this reason, one of the duas
that the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
would make every night, remember this
verse, he'd read it every night
and he would make a dua every night,
learning from this verse.
He would make dua every morning before
the sunrise and every evening before the
sunset.
Oh Allah, do not place me in charge of
my own affairs for the blink of an eye
ever.
Because if the human being is handed
over to his own devices, he will
self-destruct.
He will destroy himself thinking that he
is benefiting himself.
And so because of this, I'll let you in
on a I don't want to say a secret, but a
kind of meaning in the
prayers
dua of
dua that Allah teaches the prophet Sam
the dua of the dua of the dua of
you'll notice something very interesting
about how they speak when they are
making dua
because the human being is so hasty
because we are so shortsighted because
we don't really know what's good for us
and we don't really know what's bad for
us and we're very easily swindled and
tricked and taken off of the path and we
are so guidance at every turn and
moment.
You'll notice that the prophets and
messengers in the Quran
when they make dua to Allah for
something having to do with the
hereafter
or having to do with righteousness,
they will ask Allah for it specifically.
They will mention it. But when they make
dua for something of the dunya, they
leave it ambiguous.
What does that mean? Ambiguous meaning
they don't specifically ask for
something specific of the dunya because
they don't know if it is going to be
good for them or bad.
You listen for instance to
Aub was in a state of extreme
difficulty.
He was sick. He was poor. his family was
were were had passed away. He was in
such a state of difficulty. Some of the
companions mentioned that he remained in
that difficulty for 18 years.
Now we listen to how Aubis
made dua for Allah to relieve that
difficulty to give him his health back
to give him his wealth back to give him
his children back. How did he make dua
for that? He didn't say, "Oh Allah, take
away the illness." He didn't say, "Oh
Allah, give me my children back." He
didn't say, "Give me my wealth back."
Why? Because he doesn't know if that's
better for him. Maybe it's better for
him to stay sick. And maybe the only
thing standing between him and the
sinfulness or misguidance or the
hellfire is illness. And that's what's
better for him. He doesn't know. And so
how does
call out to Allah?
He left it ambiguous.
He said, "Oh Allah, I have been
afflicted with difficulty and you are
the most merciful
at your discretion."
In
it's mentioned that
when he made dua he said oh Allah is
narrated that he said oh Allah relieve
me and remedy my illness if you know
that to be good for me.
So he leaves it ambiguous. Misam, he's
wandering through the desert. He arrives
at Median.
He sees the two girls that are waiting
to draw water from the well at the
watering hole. He helps them. He goes
under the shade of a tree and he makes
dua. He has no wealth, no food. He's in
a strange place. All he has is the
clothes on his back. He's terrified.
He's being hunted down by Pharaoh. And
what is his dua?
Oh Allah, I need everything of good that
you will give me. He didn't say feed me.
He didn't say heal me. He didn't say
take me back into the good graces of
Pharaoh. None of that. Take me back to
my homeland. No, his dua was ambiguous.
Oh Allah, give me that which is you know
to be good for me. I need everything
that you have of good to give me in this
world. Whatever your discretion
dictates.
And so it goes in in the affairs of the
hereafter. No, we find the dua to be
very specific.
Oh Allah forgive me my sins. Oh Allah
increase me in knowledge. Oh Allah in
right raise the truth and destroy
those who are fighting against your
religion and your people. These duas are
issues of the hereafter. Allah has
already told us that these are good for
us in any case. So we make dua for that
specifically. But in the dunya, we have
no idea. Ask a man
who is at the end of something that he
asked for and sought out in his life
that turned out to be a nightmare. How
many people How many people will make
dua? I need to get married to this
woman. It can't be any other woman. It
has to be this exact woman. And then
what happens? His life turns into a
disaster place.
She wasn't right for him. She wasn't
good for him. He wasn't good for her.
How many of How many people pine over
and polish and wax and and and
you know give so much energy?
How many fret over the car that they
buy? They have no idea that that car is
going to be the purpose of their death.
They're going to be dying in that car.
That is their coffin that they're
polishing. They have no idea how many
people fight to catch a flight
not knowing that that's going to be
their last flight etc etc. The human
being has no idea what is good for him,
what is bad for him without Allah
telling us. And because of our haste and
our emotion and lack of knowledge and
lack of discipline,
we ask Allah to make those decisions for
us. We try our best. We use our best
judgment. But we do not become
ungrateful when Allah doesn't give us
exactly what we think we want. And it is
of the vast mercy and grace of Allah
that he doesn't give us what we want,
but rather he gives us what we need and
what is good for us. Because if we got
everything that we wanted, not one of us
would be here today. We ask Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
that he subhanahu wa ta'ala give us the
patience and the good thoughts and
estimate of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
that he make us of those who are
grateful when they are given of those
who are patient when they are tried and
of those who are repentant when they sin
for indeed these three traits are the
hallmark of the people of paradise and
righteousness
Alhamdulillah.